Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Vi ricordate quel viaggio
bellissimo che avete fatto?
Quello che raccontate sempre,
quello che vi fa sorridere ed emozionare
ogni volta che ne parlate.
E ogni volta che lo riportate alla mente
rivivete le sensazioni più belle,
i momenti più intensi,
i colori, i suoni, i profumi,
quasi come foste ancora lì.
Ecco, non è "quasi";
voi siete ancora lì, ogni volta
che lo riportate alla mente.
È così incredibilmente vero
perché è vero!
Quantomeno per il vostro cervello.
Già, perché il cervello non distingue
tra realtà e immaginazione.
Mi spiego meglio: se un'esperienza
la vivete sul serio, realmente,
oppure se la immaginate o la ricordate,
per il cervello non fa differenza,
è la stessa cosa.
E di conseguenza
reagisce allo stesso modo.
Ve ne do una dimostrazione:
guardate qui!
Kevin, do you want some lemon?
Do you want to try some bites?
Try a big bite!
Big bite, big bite!
What do you think?
Pretty good?
Do you want to try some more?
No more lemon? No?
Anything else?
All right, back to something else.
Cambiato qualcosa nella vostra bocca?
Il limone è nel video.
Ma la salivazione è vostra!
Se è vero che il cervello non distingue
tra realtà e immaginazione,
e abbiamo scoperto che è vero,
allora possiamo permetterci di sbagliare
e imparare dai nostri errori
semplicemente simulando,
evitando così che gli errori
abbiano ripercussioni reali.
Molti giocatori di basket si allenano
attraverso esercizi di visualizzazione:
immaginano di tirare e di fare canestro.
Vi sto dicendo che si stanno
allenando per finta!
Ma... indovinate un po’?
La percentuale dei canestri fatti,
quelli veri, aumenta!
Il cervello non distingue
tra realtà e immaginazione.
E cosa accade quando giochiamo?
Pensateci bene:
giocare significa fare qualcosa
immaginando di fare qualcos’altro.
Il bello del gioco è che è esperienziale,
fa sì che le persone agiscano.
E lo fa in un contesto metaforico,
lontano da quello reale,
così che non ci siano
giudizio e valutazione,
ma solo un’espressione non filtrata
dei propri comportamenti.
Il bello del gioco è che è immaginario
- e quindi, per il cervello, reale.
I bambini passano automaticamente
dal gioco all’apprendimento.
Loro entrano in questo magico mondo,
e ne escono cresciuti,
con nuove consapevolezze.
Noi adulti no, abbiamo bisogno
di qualche passaggio in più:
entriamo nel mondo del gioco,
lo viviamo appieno,
ne assaporiamo le sensazioni
positive e negative,
di soddisfazione o di frustrazione;
e poi abbiamo bisogno di fermarci.
Per riflettere, per capire
quello che è successo,
guardarci dall’alto:
così riusciamo a imparare.
Questo è il significato
dell’apprendimento.
Ma è inutile parlare a voce,
raccontarvi a voce
che cosa significa un’esperienza:
bisogna provarla!
E allora mettiamo in pratica, facciamo
un esercizio pratico tutti insieme.
Vorrei creare, insieme, un esercizio
che è il più veloce del mondo;
vorremmo creare insieme
l’esercizio più veloce del TEDx!
Un gioco che dura 11 secondi.
Quindi vi chiedo cortesemente, adesso,
di mettervi in coppie.
Scegliete la persona
alla vostra destra o sinistra,
e formate una coppia;
facciamo un gioco tutti insieme,
tutti tutti tutti tutti…
Scegliete una persona;
se non la trovate la prendete davanti
o la prendete indietro.
Accoppiatevi!
Grazie… tutti quanti…
vediamo se riusciamo ad alzare le luci.
Avete creato la coppia?
Bene, tutti quanti, anche lassù?
Bene, adesso vi chiedo…
Oh, siete già emozionati,
ancora dobbiamo cominciare!
Vi chiedo cortesemente di prendere
la mano destra del vostro nuovo partner,
in questo modo,
e di appoggiare i gomiti
sul bracciolo della sedia.
Attenzione, vi chiedo di mettere
il massimo impegno in questa sfida.
Perché quello che vi chiedo adesso,
in questi 11 secondi,
è di ottenere
il massimo punteggio possibile,
dove io ottengo un punto quando
la mano del mio partner tocca la sedia,
e il mio partner ottiene un punto
quando la mia mano tocca la sedia.
Il massimo impegno in questa sfida.
Siete pronti?
3,2,1… via!
Impegno! Impegno!
Ok, stop, grazie.
Fermi fermi, gli 11 secondi sono finiti!
Finiti!
Altrimenti non è il gioco
più veloce del TEDx, signori!
Fermi tutti.
Allora, vediamo se riesco
a vedervi un pochino.
Cerchiamo di capire
che cosa è successo:
quanti di voi hanno fatto
meno di tre punti?
Alzate le mani, così riesco
a vedervi: meno di tre punti!
Ooohh!
Quanti di voi hanno fatto
più di cinque punti?
Vediamo un pochino,
Più di dieci?
Chi è che si sente orgoglioso
del proprio numero, me lo urlate?
Forte, forte, forte!
Wow, una mandria di mucche!
Che è successo?
Un numero, forte!
25!
Come è possibile, scusatemi, 25?
E soprattutto,
come mai alcuni
hanno totalizzato 1 punto,
mentre c’è qualcuno che ne ha fatti 25?
Le risposte sono due.
Uno: ha barato!
Che è poi quello
che normalmente la gente pensa
quando qualcuno ottiene
un risultato migliore del suo!
Oppure, ha rotto uno schema.
Ha ascoltato l’obiettivo,
ha ascoltato le regole,
e ha deciso di interpretarle
a suo favore.
L’obiettivo è di ottenere
il maggior punteggio possibile.
Il maggior punteggio possibile,
non di battere il partner!
Ma noi no, noi dobbiamo vincere,
vincere nei confronti dell’avversario,
vincere nei confronti del nemico!
Che poi era il vostro partner
fino a 11 secondi fa,
ma ce lo siamo già dimenticati, va bene?
Tutto questo accade
nel nostro cervello, automaticamente.
È automatico che se io sono
davanti a una sfida, la devo vincere.
È automatico che se metto
le mani in questo modo
è braccio di ferro, una prova di forza.
È così da sempre…
Viviamo di automatismi:
prendiamo decisioni in base
alle nostre esperienze passate.
Il che la maggior parte delle volte
è vero, ed è efficace:
l’ho già fatto, so come funziona,
riapplico lo stesso comportamento
ogni volta che trovo
una situazione simile.
Siamo fatti così biologicamente,
è un sistema che il cervello usa
per risparmiare energia,
per ottenere lo stesso risultato
con un minore sforzo.
Un sistema quasi sempre
efficace, ma non sempre.
Ci sono situazioni in cui riapplichiamo
lo stesso comportamento,
nonostante non funzioni più,
nonostante non ci porti più
il risultato che vogliamo.
Comportamento che prima aveva
un senso, e adesso non ce l’ha.
Ma che è entrato ormai
nel nostro pilota automatico,
e quindi non mettiamo
neanche più in discussione.
È qui che dobbiamo
uscire dal gioco e fermarci.
Fermarci e capire che...
cavoli, abbiamo sbagliato!
ci siamo cascati,
che sciocchi che siamo stati.
Sciocchi?
E cosa importa?
Era un gioco, non è vita reale!
E per fortuna!
Abbiamo perso,
ma abbiamo perso per finta.
Ma abbiamo imparato - e fidatevi,
abbiamo imparato per davvero.
Se adesso rifacessimo lo stesso gioco,
quanti di voi otterrebbero
un punteggio più alto
rispetto a quello
che avete ottenuto prima?
Dimostrato:
avete imparato a giocare meglio.
Ora, se ritrovaste lo stesso gioco
nella vita reale,
le stesse dinamiche
in una situazione vera,
quanti di voi cambierebbero
comportamento,
dopo aver visto e fatto questo gioco?
Bravi, avete trasformato un gioco
in apprendimento.
Un esempio per voi
di quanto sia difficile
cambiare un comportamento
una volta che è dentro di noi.
Un esperimento.
Una stanza con 12 scimmie.
Dentro questa stanza c'è una scala,
e sopra la scala un casco di banane.
Le scimmie vedono le banane
e vanno per prenderle.
Ma sulle scale
sono stati messi dei sensori,
collegati a delle docce fredde;
ogni volta che i sensori
vengono calpestati,
le docce fredde si attivano.
Le scimmie vanno su, docce fredde,
brrrr, torniamo indietro!
Si spengono. Riprovano, docce fredde,
torniamo indietro, si spengono.
Dopo tre-quattro volte, le scimmie
decidono di restare giù e asciutte:
hanno imparato in base alle esperienze.
Brave!
Ma è a questo punto
che i sensori vengono disattivati.
Ora le docce
non sono più attivabili;
di conseguenza,
le banane sono raggiungibili.
Cosa fanno le scimmie?
Niente!
Stanno ferme.
Perché?
Perché la loro esperienza passata
condiziona i comportamenti attuali.
Ma non finisce qui:
una scimmia viene sostituita
con una nuova, fresca, vergine.
Vede le banane,
va per prendere le banane.
Le altre cosa fanno?
La bloccano!
Fin quando la scimmia non rinuncia.
La scimmia rinuncia
senza neanche sapere il motivo
per cui non può prendere le sue banane.
Ancora: cambiano,
una seconda scimmia.
La seconda scimmia vede
le banane, va per prenderle,
le altre scimmie la bloccano.
Tutte, compresa la prima!
Attenzione: compresa la prima,
che sta bloccando la seconda
senza neanche sapere il motivo per cui.
È come se qualcuno venisse da voi
e vi dicesse, non si può fare.
E voi, ma perché?
- Boh, non lo so!
Ma sono scimmie, noi umani
siamo molto più intelligenti…
Una per una vengono cambiate
tutte le scimmie,
fino a quando nella stanza
non si trovano 12 scimmie,
nessuna delle quali
va a prendere le banane,
sa il motivo per cui non può.
Sapete quante scimmie
hanno dovuto sostituire,
prima che ce ne fosse una che dicesse,
io voglio provare, sulla mia pelle?
48.
48 scimmie, prima che ce ne fosse una
che avesse il coraggio.
Ora, la mia domanda per voi è:
chi di voi vuole essere la 48° scimmia?
Chi di voi ha la forza,
l’impeto, e anche il coraggio,
di alzarsi, nonostante le difficoltà,
nonostante le resistenze degli altri,
e dire, 'io vado, voglio provare'?
Ecco signori, come vedete
abbiamo imparato un po’ di cose,
e l’abbiamo fatto giocando.
Ma se c’è una cosa
che vorrei portaste a casa
da questi minuti passati insieme,
non è una consapevolezza,
ma una domanda,
la domanda più importante.
Quando vi trovate davanti a un ostacolo
che sembra insormontabile,
nel lavoro, nella relazione,
con voi stessi,
prima di rinunciare a salire le scale,
fatevi questa semplice domanda:
Cosa sto dando per scontato?
Chissà che non siate voi,
la 48° scimmia.
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)